JUNE 15TH DEADLINE FOR HIS
LAWYERS TO FINISH REVIEWING
3.7 MILLION FILES SEIZED DURING
A RAID EARLIER THIS YEAR.
>> Bret: KEVIN, THE REPUBLICAN
SENATE COMMITTEE ALSO LEVELING
SOME NEW AND SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS
TONIGHT.
>> CHUCK GRASSLEY QUESTIONED THE
ACCURACY OF THE TESTIMONY BY THE
COFOUNDER BEHIND THE DOSSIER.
COFOUNDER GLENN SIMPSON TOLD
SENATE INVESTIGATORS SUCH AS
FIRMS WORK ON THE TRUMP DOSSIER
ENDED IN SEPTEMBER 2016.
CONTRARY TO MR. SIMPSON'S DENIAL
IN THE STAFF INTERVIEW,
ACCORDING TO THE FBI AND OTHERS,
FUSION DID CONTINUE DOSSIER WORK
FOR A NEW CLIENT AFTER THE
ELECTION.
THAT CLIENT WAS DANIEL JONES.
ACCORDING TO GRASSLEY, JONES AND
HIS FIRM      HIRED SIMPSON TO C
HIS FIRM      HIRED SIMPSON TO N
HIS FIRM      HIRED SIMPSON TO I
HIS FIRM      HIRED SIMPSON TO U
HIS FIRM      HIRED SIMPSON TO E
RESEARCH SO IT COULD BE SHARED
WITH CAPITOL HILL, THE FBI AND
THE MEDIA AFTER THE ELECTION.
GRASSLEY SAID THEIR STATEMENTS
ARE COVERED BY THE FEDERAL